أجنبي لقد
نشأت في نيويورك وكنت
أستقل مترو الأنفاق منذ أن كنت طفلاً،
يمكنك رؤية أي شيء وكل شيء في مترو
الأنفاق، ويمكن أن يكون لديك شخص بلا مأوى
بجوار مليونير،
ويمكن أن تعرف شخصًا لديه
وشم كامل  الوجه المجاور مثل
رجل محافظ وبالنسبة لي هذا
جميل، هؤلاء مثل الأشخاص الذين
أحبهم، هؤلاء هم الأشخاص الذين
نشأت حولهم، هؤلاء هم الأشخاص الذين يديرون
المجتمع، لذلك هذا ما أردت
تقديمه، عفوًا يا سيدي، لقد رسمتك
هذا جميل ورائع، سعدت
بلقائك، لقد كنت
أقوم بتجربة العديد من
الأشياء المختلفة، ما أدركته هو أن معظم
الناس في المجتمع لا يحبون الفن، إنه على
الأرجح مثل
شيء متخصص لذلك كنت أفكر كيف يمكنني مزج
ذلك مع شيء ما  الذي سيستمتع به معظم الناس ويجعله سهل
الهضم بالنسبة
للناس، لذلك أقوم بخلط الرسم ولكن بالنسبة
لهم يتعلق الأمر أكثر بإنسانيته
وجعل شخص ما يشعر بأنه مرئي
وقيمة الصدمة وجودته الصحية،
فالناس يحبونك و  سيقولون لي
مثل الرجل، أنا لا أعرف ما هو، حتى أنني لا
أهتم بالفن ولكنك أنت، أنا مهووس
بعملك منذ أن كان عمري 16 عامًا
ربما قبل ستة أشهر تقريبًا، أصبحت
الفنان البصري الأكثر متابعة  على شبكة
الإنترنت بأكملها،
سيأتون الآن إلى المعرض
الليلة، وقد يمنحهم ذلك
منظورًا مختلفًا، يُطلق على
العرض بأكمله اسم "تحت الأرض"
لأنه تجول حول العالم
مسافرًا في عوالم تحت الأرض والمعنى
الثاني هو أنني أشعر وكأنني  "أنا
فنان تحت الأرض لأنه لم
يكن لدي أي عمل في أي معرض أو كان
لدي طفل معرض منفرد
من برونكس كان يحصل على قسائم الرعاية الاجتماعية
والطعام في هذا كما تعلمون، لقد
حافظت البوابة على الصناعة، لقد شعرت دائمًا أنني
شعرت دائمًا أنني لم أفعل ذلك"  لا أنتمي،
أشعر وكأنني كنت أستعد لهذه
اللحظة منذ أن كان عمري 14 عامًا منذ أن
بدأت الرسم
لهذا العرض، كان علي حقًا أن أظهر
للناس أنك تعرف ما أنا قادر على فعله
لأن الناس يعتقدون أنني مثل
هذه العلامة تمامًا  نجح tocker بين عشية وضحاها ولكنك
تعلم أنني أشعر أن لدي عمقًا أكبر
من ذلك وأردت حقًا بذل كل
جهدي حتى يتمكن الناس من رؤيته
وآمل أن ينالوا إعجابهم